[Music]
you said the stripper name is very
important you were big big dick Ritchie
yes and there's big dick Ritchie like
that and but the name is very important
like you can go with you can get the
wrong name and then you're done right
yeah I could see that if you had the
wrong name you wouldn't make a lot of
tips right off the bat like going to
this guy over here right
you have you been working on your male
stripper name I know I never it never
occurred to me before I don't know what
I would be you know no idea you know the
you help me what would I be what do you
look at me and what do you see what
would be and this be honest we're all
honest here and if I don't like it I'll
cut it out of the show I think I think
big red could work big red big red yeah
big red like a Viking with a Viking with
the helmet yeah James like tearaway
armor you know like I'm gonna here to
pillage your village and pillage your
village my way with you women and what
about moves is there a move you could
show me it would be great if you could
show me a move you can show me what to
do alright okay fine you're gonna make
money as a male stripper yeah the real
the move is the body roll that's what I
got oh there's a bottom the top body
roll okay okay so if you got a girl on a
chair right she's here yeah you've got
this kind of like right there
[Applause]
she's on the chair right there where is
she I've lost the chair Wailea why am I
looking at you look at oh no you're on
your own
good you don't know love is the Andy
sitting there watching both of us yeah
and I don't have any singles
you